Harry we've noticed that at various
points in this long and somewhat
complicated letter Paul seems to come to
kind of a halt and start again
we've just had three chapters on the
relationship of Israel to the people in
Christ the Gentile people in Christ in
God's plan and then with chapter 12:1
there's a kind of a therefore in a halt
and a new start what's going on yeah in
chapters 12 through 14 or 15 at least 14
maybe into 15 Paul is engaged in
exhortation or parent Isis encouraging
people to behave in certain ways and
Paul's letters often end with some
parenthetical comments like this and
exhortation to tomorrow behavior these
comments in enrollments seem to be at
least part of the overall argument
remember he's been concerned to say that
even though Torah as a way of relating
to God or an exclusive way of relating
to God no longer obtains we who are in
Christ are not free of ethical
obligations in fact we need to be slaves
to righteousness uses that language from
one of the earlier chapters so in some
ways this is a culmination of that
argument about the moral seriousness of
the Christian life and it may also be a
point in the letter way he's addressing
some concrete issues and they the Roman
community and as we said when we started
our conversations about Romans there's a
debate among interpreters of Romans
about whether Paul is as concerned
primarily with a situation in in Rome
and you would call our solution was that
he's aware of issues in Rome but he's he
has a larger agenda in mind I think
that's clear here a lot of the language
in in these chapters in especially 12
and 13 that we're looking at today is
reminiscent of language that he had used
in other contexts particularly the
language of the body of Christ which is
very important in in Chapter 12 the that
language is an image he had used in
first Corinthians right at a time when
he was trying to get that community to
cohere or it's quite clear what the
splits were on the D and the unity of
the county is huge yeah I don't although
there might be some device
of issues and he'll get into those in
chapter 4 Joe the community doesn't seem
to be on the on the verge of splitting
up miss earth seem to be the case in or
at least at some points in in Corinth so
he can reuse that at that language about
that the one body and all the members of
the body in order to to ground his his
language about the marks of a true
Christian in chapter 12 verse 9 which is
a more general list of the virtues that
oughta mark a Christian life let love be
genuine hate what is evil hold fast to
what is good love one of the other with
mutual affection outdo one another in
showing honor these are all rather
general they're certainly valid and do
not lag in zeal be art and and spirit
serve the Lord rejoice in hope be
patient and suffering persevere in
prayer so that good expectations over
all grounded in this notion that we're
all part of one new reality created by
God's act of of redemption of
reconciliation he gets a little more
specific actually I want to go back to
the way in which he begins okay because
I think it's also characteristic of of
Paul's ethical excitations in chapter 12
verses 1 and following he appeals to the
brothers and sisters by the mercy of God
to present your bodies as a living
sacrifice holy acceptable to God
spiritual worship so he takes cultic
image yeah very much and uses it for the
realities of Christian life Christian
life is is sacred it's sanctified and
that's something that was very important
to him in 1st Corinthians when talking
about sexual morality absolutely right
the sanctity of the Christian life
worship is is what you do yeah and what
you do with your body yeah not what you
do one Sunday Shabbat yeah ok
and then his his other general
exhortation do not be conformed to this
world but be transformed by the renewing
of your minds we heard a lot about
transformation the process of
transformation that has begun through
baptism yeah and it's working itself out
in the life of the Spirit groaning and
praying within us and I think Paul is a
alluding to that here and an essential
part of that is having the mind of
the attitude the orientation that which
which makes it impossible for you to sin
which makes you a slave of righteousness
uses language earlier on this having the
mind of Christ is something that is used
in in other contexts in Philippians for
instance the great craft that line yeah
they have that mind in you which was in
here we go with a form of God did not
consider equality with God something to
be grasped right so having that attitude
that having the mind of Christ is not
asking what would Jesus do oh no right
now it's it's it's exemplify or living
out that fidelity to God that he's been
in that great story history yeah all the
way along and that life of fidelity is
one that also exemplifies hope and works
itself out in love and that triad that
we saw in Romans 4 through aid of faith
hope and love is again writ large on the
whole of Romans and what's going to
motivate all of the excitations in these
chapters is the love command that we're
going to see in chapter 13 verse 8 need
one just one quick thing on that and
that first two verses that do not be
conformed to this world but be
transformed the Greek for that is what
becomes our metamorphosis so
transformation is not that I wake up
with less hair tomorrow morning or a
longer beard transformation as
metamorphosis it's a shift I'm a new
person in Jesus Christ and the baptism
is the start of that it's not it's not
an accrual of slightly more virtue it's
a shift of the self right I think that's
going right now but within that larger
context there are a couple of issues
that Paul takes up which which are
probably hot topics in the Roman
community okay
and the first of these is in chapter 13
and this is the text that's often been
used in various ways and misused I think
some Christian circles to suggest that
we owe absolute obedience to civil
authority
yeah certainly we talked about
post-holocaust the hour absolutely
reflections on romans the last time out
and this text is one that would have
been used by
that that's easy absolutely and was been
was used by the church that went along
with it that's right which was a very
sizable group right and in terms of
thinking about that canonically I think
we also had to take into account that
they are prophetic witnesses within the
New Testament that say the authorities
of this world are subject to the
authority of God at Roman certainly is
not there but revelations usually and
some of the sayings of Jesus agreed okay
but what then is is Paul really worried
about here he's not articulating a
general theory about the relationship
between religion or Christian belief or
living in Christ to civil authority I
think he has a rather specific human
mind and it comes I think at the very
end of this dissection and that's paid
to all we'll just do them yeah taxes to
whom taxes I do revenue to whom revenue
was due respect whom respect is due
honor to whom honor is due I think there
are some people in the the Christian
community of Rome the community of
believers in Rome yeah who are asking
the question that was posed to Jesus
absolutely
do we pay taxes to Caesar exactly are we
by doing so engaged in the idolatry that
Paul condemned through the in Chapter
one interlocutor there in Chapter done
and Paul in effect answers yes you got
to pay a taxes now there might be some
pragmatic yeah consider Prudential
thought yep there are some theoretical
calibrations that civil authority does
serve God's purposes and having the
freedom in Christ that we have is not an
imitation in the civil order how far is
this driven by his strong sense that the
world as we know it is coming to an end
you said earlier we can't really work
out a long salvation history with Paul
because he doesn't think there's time is
it true that we can't work out a
doctrine of government over the long
haul because think about the long haul I
think that's quite right although it's
interesting as we move toward the end of
Romans to think about how much
eschatology is how much apocalyptic
speculation is here in in Romans you
know some people suggest that Paul moved
out off our oh I know here's Joe his
belief in the imminent wrath
Meishan of things by the time he writes
Romans I don't think so either but he
doesn't emphasize it that's true in a
way that he does let's say in first
Thessalonians or in Corinthians in the
passage you alluded to all true about
the shape of this world passing away
yeah so I believe he he does sense that
the shape of the world is passing away
and he can sense it in the life of the
believer the life infused by the spirit
but still there are obligations in the
meantime yeah
and and then the trick becomes for us
it's become a very long mean time right
that's right and do we still hold the
same strictures yeah and right after
this this section we have a hint of
Paul's eschatological horizon still
operating this is in chapter 13 verses
11 and following right after the
emphasis and love command right besides
the issue know what time it is how it is
now the moment for you to wake from
sleep so yeah there's a timely call
mm-hmm to moral responsibility again
yeah for salvation is nearer to us now
than when we became believers nearer but
not necessarily right around that's a
universal truth a I kind of like that
right you could always preach that it's
always nearer and then first for moments
that was on the steeple of a church in
Dallas near which I used to live for the
night is far gone the day is near let us
then lay aside the works of darkness and
put on the armor of light so Paul uses
eschatological hope and the hope of
transformation again to ground his
ethical appeal and it's interesting that
these are the verses that Augustine
absolutely at the moment of his final
conversion to Christ
let us live honorably is in the day not
in revelry in drunkenness not in
debauchery and licentiousness not in
quarreling and jealousy instead put on
the Lord Jesus Christ and make no
provision for the flesh to gratify
desires that notion of the flesh and the
fall of man today that's the source of
our problems and the putting on Lord
Jesus Christ can take us back to baptism
chapter 6 what do you do when you're
going down in Baptism you put on Christ
and come up that transformed person no
longer conformed to the world but
transformed
in any case getting back to the center
of these hortatory chapters and I think
these chapters do have a kind of ringg
compositional structure to them and it
all centers on chapter 13 verses 8
through 10
oh no and anything except to love one
another for the one who loves another
has fulfilled the law this is that theme
of absolutely that they had the moral
earnestness of the Christian life being
what the law actually is really means
what the law really means if you read it
right yeah any new sites the
commandments don't commit adultery
murder steal or covet and any other
command but they're all summed up and
love your neighbor as yourself from
Leviticus yep love does no wrong to a
neighbor therefore love is the
fulfilling of the law so remember Paul
starting out in Romans do we abrogate
the law by our gospel nomemes we support
it and that's in his mind here I'm
saying that love and one of the few
places where he echoes what we find in
the gospel tradition it's very similar
to what the Gospels say Jesus says about
how you fulfill the law all right good